now there will be no bourbon jokes used
to introduce Ray Milland he's an expert
comedian a gifted dramatic actor and a
winner of the Academy Award he's here to
present the Oscar for the best
performance by an actress in a
supporting role mr. Ray Milland thank
you Paul one of the first things they
tried to drum into an actor's head is a
sense of timing I think my sense of
timing would be way off tonight if I
didn't read these nominations those
nominated for the best performance by an
actress in a supporting role are Ethel
Barrymore in pinky 20th Century Fox
Celeste Holm in come to the stable 20th
Century Fox Elsa Lanchester in come to
the stable 20th Century Fox Lissa D's
McCambridge in all the king's men a
Robert Ross in production Columbia Ethel
Waters in pinking 20th Century Fox where
have the envelope please
the winner is Mercedes McCambridge
dear ladies and gentlemen is one of
those affair
it can only happen in master affair down
is coming a young lady who for her first
screen role receives one of the coveted
and highest awards that this our
industry can give
now
in the Academy presentations she's
approaching the mic I'm aware those who
have contributed to this moment and
thankful for them but I would like to
say to every waiting actor hold on
look what can happen thank you very much
congratulations presenters
short for very distinguished speech and
thanks to you was play in the laugh